bonjour donc je suis ronan moelle je
suis sexologue à brest et co fondateur
d'une société qui s'appelle il toucy et
qui propose des applications pour
améliorer la sexualité et j'ai remarqué
dans mon activité que les gens que je
voyais partager un certain nombre de
points communs
en règle générale déjà la bonne volonté
ensuite aussi la difficulté à comprendre
ce qui leur arrive et ils vivaient des
difficultés dans leur sexualité sans
vraiment comprendre pourquoi et sans
comment vraiment trouvé le chemin pour
en sortir
souvent aussi l'impression qu'ils
étaient un peu tout seul là dedans
bien qu'ils aient un partenaire
l'impression d'être le seul à faire des
efforts et ne pas comprendre ce qui se
passait chez l'autre et même quand j'ai
un couple en face de moi
les deux ont cette réaction et c'est ça
que je trouve très intéressant là dedans
c'est que la majorité de ces gens sont
de bonne volonté n'arrive pas forcément
à s'entendre donc je suis très content
d'avoir été invité à participer au tedx
car le thème des tadjiks de cette année
c'est comprendre le monde et je pense
que vu la place que la sexualité prend
dans nos vies comprendre la sexualité
c'est un petit peu aussi comprendre le
monde
alors qu'est ce que c'est que la
sexualité je vais être obligé de faire
simple parce que on pourra y passer la
soirée voire plus déjà à la base la
sexualité c'est de l'instinct si nous
sommes là tous ce soir si nous existons
c'est parce que tous nos ancêtres ont eu
cet instinct en eux et pendant des
milliers d'années
ça n'a été qu'une question d'instinct et
c'est seulement il y à quelques
centaines d'années qu'on a décidé de
commencer à mettre des règles mettre des
normes là dedans
et pour ça on a fait appel à l'autorité
de l'époque c'est-à-dire l'église on a
donc demandé pour décider ce que ferait
des couples sexuellement actifs à des
célibataires abstinents vous voyez que
dès le départ on n'avait pas réuni les
meilleures conditions
c'est un peu comme si on demandait à des
gens régime de fer menu d'une nouvelle
encre et donc pour transmettre ces
normes
on a tout de suite créé en fait la
notion de bien et de mal
une norme qui était donc une sexualité
hétérosexuelle
dans le cadre du mariage
de l'affection et pour faire des enfants
et donc tout ce qui sortait de la était
forcément hors norme voire anormal et
c'est la première difficulté de la
sexualité c'est qu'en fait la norme en
matière de sexualité c'est d'être hors
norme
si on inventait une machine qui pouvait
lire dans nos pensées et retranscrire
tout ce que nous avons pensé un jour je
pense que nous serions assez nombreux
prêts à payer cher pour faire sauter
quelques lignes sur le texte
les seules limites qu'il doit y avoir en
matière de sexualité
ça doit être le respect de la loi et
surtout le respect de votre partenaire
et de vous
en dehors de ça il n'y a aucune règle
pourtant on a toujours ce sentiment dès
qu'on sort de cette norme d'être bizarre
on te voir pervers pervers peuvent
d'ailleurs s'entendre comme qui part de
la voit donc le simple fait de faire
l'amour avec une contraception
compte tenu de la voie qui a été décidé
au départ fait de vous des pervers et
pour transmettre cette norme
eh bien on a mis en place une éducation
nous avons tous reçu une éducation et
cette éducation elle commence très tôt
elle est double c'est une éducation
verticale c'est à dire nos parents de
grands-parents mais c'est aussi une
éducation horizontale la société les
gens qui nous entourent et dès le début
on a été influencé je vais vous donner
l'exemple par exemple d'un petit enfant
de 1 an à qui sont parents viennent
enlever la couche et qu'il met dans le
bain pour lui donner pour le laver cet
enfant en profite pour partir explorer
la partie de son corps qu'il n'a pas pu
découvrir dans la journée imaginez le
parent qui se retourne et qui le
découvrent suivant sa réaction
il va commencer à guider le chemin qui
va suivre cet enfant si la réaction est
brutale touche pas assez sale entre le
ton la surprise l'utilisation de
l'impératif d'habitude réservé aux
choses importantes
les mauves ont bien être imprégné touche
pas ses salles ok si au contraire la
bord est plus délicat
il peut être utile de faire passer
certains messages pour la société si
l'enfant continue à jouer avec ses
organes génitaux au public
ça pourrait lui causer des problèmes
plus tard mais s'il part on le dit
tranquillement aux dix ans battue c'est
ça c'est à toi ça appartient par contre
tu fais pas ça quand il ya du monde
quand tu es dans ta chambre tu fais ce
que tu veux mais pas quand il ya des
gens vous voyez que ces deux bébés dont
je viens de parler ont déjà pris des
chemins différents et ça va continuer
comme ça la société aussi va s'en
charger la prochaine fois vous dire au
supermarché profitez-en pour passer par
le rayon sous vêtements pour enfants et
vous verrez ce que réservent aux petits
garçons et au petit chic trois quatre
ans les petits garçons ils ont des
boxers des slip bleu marine noir marron
avec un super héros là en ce moment le
thème à la mode c'est star wars
les petits garçons et se promène avec un
chevalier jedi et parfois méchant muni
d'un sabre laser je pense que freud
aurait apprécié le symbolique les
petites shirel ondes et culotte blanche
rose clair bleu clair avec des
princesses asexué des petits coeurs ou
des liquoreux voyez que le message est
pas tout à fait le même déjà et même
dans la couleur de sous vêtements est-ce
que c'est surprenant qu'un enfant 3 4
ans et des salissures dans son sous
vêtement le soir il apprend la propreté
même un adulte c'est une zone qui vit
sauf que le petit garçon soir il va
mettre son boxer à laver on verra rien
dedans dès le départ la petite fille on
va tout de suite voir toute salissure
on lui fait peser une sorte de pression
hygiéniste dès le départ ça peut
paraître un peu tiré par les cheveux
mais on la retrouve jusqu'au mariage
dans la robe blanche symbole de pureté
sous-entendu de virginité et ça va
continuer comme ça dans le langage
argotique des petits garçons sont des
branleurs un garçon ça se vende les
petites filles sont des pisseuses
et puis même les parents pleins de bonne
volonté vont faire passer des messages
malgré eux ils vont montrer leurs
enfants des films pornos jeu sur corner
montrer à vos enfants les premiers en
général c'est blanche neige cendrillon
la belle au bois dormant
on montre ça pourquoi j'appelle ça des
films pornographiques
lorsque ça à peu près aussi proche de la
réalité que le sont les films
pornographiques classique plutôt destiné
à un public masculin dans les walt
disney on montera des enfants
particulièrement influençable surtout
les filles que si elles sont belles
si elles ont une jolie robe elles vont
croiser le chemin d'un prince charmant
ils vont tomber amoureux avoir des tas
d'enfants
au passage on sait pas comment et vivre
heureux jusqu'à la fin de leurs jours
sous-entendu il n'y a pas d'efforts à
faire si c'est le bon ça doit
fonctionner si c'est compliqué c'est que
ça doit être le bon rapidement derrière
malheureusement il y aura les vrais
films pornographiques je dis
malheureusement parce que l'âge moyen de
visionnage du premier film
pornographique en france maintenant est
arrivé à 11 ans ce qui veut dire que la
majorité des enfants voient leur premier
film pornographique avant même d'être
pubères et toutes ces influences tous
ces éléments on les subit quasiment
depuis le premier jour de notre vie
jusqu'à l'âge adulte
on essaye de se construire au milieu de
tout ça et quand on arrive à un âge de
maturité sexuelle à l'âge adulte
on a déjà un bon passif en fait un si
vous voulez une image c'est un petit peu
comme si nous étions des ordinateurs
munis d'un système d'exploitation
instinctif et sur lequel on avait
installé des tas de logiciels plus ou
moins bon voire franchement obsolète
quand ce n'est pas des virus pourtant
les gens qui ont fait cela l'ont souvent
fait plein de bonne volonté on nous a
fait passer et vous avez en vous comme
moi sans doute des tas de programmes
inadaptés
j'imagine que vos parents vous ont
appris à mettre la main devant la bouche
quand vous tous et oui c'est très
mauvaise idée
quand on met la main devant la bouche
on y répond tous nos microbes et après
on les étale sur les accoudoirs sur les
poignées de portes un peu partout comme
ça on en fait profiter tout le monde
la majorité des maladies sont transmises
par les mains c'est pas du tout une
bonne idée alors ça peut être
bienveillante pas tout c'est la figure
des gens mais idéalement faudrait mettre
le coude pas la main sauf qu'à l'époque
où on a pris l'habitude de mettre la
main on n'avait sans doute pas les mêmes
connaissances en microbiologie et
maintenant vous avez conscience d'un
programme inadapté vous allez aussi
prendre conscience de ce que c'est qu'un
conditionnement vous penserez sûrement
un mois la prochaine fois que vous serez
c'est pour ça que c'est compliqué de se
comprendre parce que nous sommes tous
des ordinateurs avec un système
d'exploitation et des logiciels
différents et deux personnes qui
essayent de se comprendre en matière de
sexualité c'est un peu un pc et un
macintosh qui essaye de communiquer et
si ça suffisait pas la nature si amy tu
vous faire gagner du temps il y en a
onze c'est premier réflexe qu'on a en
général c'est de compter et oui parce
que l'intérêt de la nature s'est pas non
plus l'intérêt de l'individu
l'intérêt de la nature c'est de faire
durer l'espèce et tout est fait pour ça
on est conditionné pour ça et quand on
fait l'amour
aux yeux de la nature ont fait un enfant
le mot sapiens existe depuis deux cent
mille ans la pilule depuis 40 ans autant
vous dire que notre cerveau n'a pas
vraiment eu le temps d'intégrer la
donner d'autant plus qu'il suffit d'un
accident de contraception pour qu'on
passe dans le concret donc ça ça va nous
influencer aussi malgré nous dans le
choix de nos partenaires par exemple qui
n'en fait pas grand chose à voir avec sa
qualité pour jouer de la guitare pour
réciter des poèmes
c'est avant tout biologique quand même
même si bien sûr les facteurs
psychologiques et sociologiques
interviennent aussi il ya très peu de
chance par exemple que vos conjoints et
le même groupe sanguin que vous irez
pourtant pas beaucoup des groupes
sanguins et s'ils ont un groupe sanguin
ils n'auront pas le même résultat en
général parce que pour faire simple en
gros un groupe sanguin correspond un
groupe immunitaire
et faire un enfant avec quelqu'un qui a
le même groupe immunitaire c'est lui
donner deux fois la même copie alors que
faire un enfant avec quelqu'un qui a un
groupe différent c'est lui donner un
champ et militaires plus vaste et
augmenter ses chances de survie face aux
maladies
pourtant quand on rencontre quelqu'un on
n'a pas cette idée en tête forcément
qu'on va faire un enfant
mais tout ça c'est déjà décidé malgré
nous par notre instinct et la nature va
continuer à fonctionner comme ça quand
on tombe amoureux là encore je suis
désolé de vous le dire c'est pas trop la
version walt disney
c'est plutôt parce que votre corps a
décidé vous aviez trouvé un partenaire
compatible pour faire des petits et
qu'il va donc déclenché au niveau de
votre cerveau des sécrétions de
substances chimiques qui en gros vous
droguez c'est plutôt sympa comme drogue
on est irrésistiblement attiré par
l'autre et ça s'est passé comme ça
depuis la nuit des temps
quand le mariage n'était pas arranger
directement à éviter les questions les
gens tomber amoureux on se dépêcher de
les marier parce qu'on savait ce qui
allait suivre derrière et quand au bout
d'un an deux ans la passion s'apaiser
parce que les sécrétions chimiques
diminué il y avait déjà un deux trois
enfants les femmes de gagner pas leur
vie les hommes n'étaient pas autonome au
niveau domestique
la société n'autorisait pas le divorce
ont continué comme ça en tant que
conjoint collaborateur
aujourd'hui on peut rester pendant
plusieurs années avec quelqu'un sans
faire d'enfant les femmes sont autonomes
les hommes aussi normalement être avec
quelqu'un c'est donc un choix et si on
le fait c'est parce qu'on veut en tirer
des bénéfices
on veut que ce soit quelque chose de
plaisant qui nous aide à nous construire
et c'est ça qu'on va retrouver par
exemple dans le désir c'est pour ça que
le désir est important même dans le mot
désiré quelqu'un on sait pas si on parle
de sexualité ou de la personne en
général et donc quand une personne ne
sent pas de désir sexuel chez l'autre
elle doute elle se sent attaqué dans son
intégralité
elle va s'inquiéter
perdre confiance en elle c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui il faut voir la sexualité
comme quelque chose de complètement
différent car toujours contre une
sexualité épanouie toujours cette nature
quand l'enfant arrive aux yeux de la
nature les parents sont plus très
intéressant éventuellement l'un des deux
pour s'occuper de l'enfant le deuxième
c'est accessoire tout le temps que les
parents passent à batifoler il ne passe
pas s'occuper du petit c'est un très
mauvaise
un pardon un très mauvais investissement
au dieu de la nature il ya d'ailleurs
des espèces ou carrément le mâle 120
après l'accouplement
quand il se fait pas mangé par la
femelle on s'en tire pas trop mal mais
par exemple dans l'espèce humaine
quand un petit arrive si la maman lui
donne le sein est là à chaque fois
qu'elle donne le sein une poussée
d'ocytocine qu'on appelle l'hormone de
l'attachement on a également 7 pouces et
quand on a un orgasme avec un partenaire
sauf que là ça va être six sept huit
fois par jour ça plus la fatigue et
réveille la nuit
le choc de la grossesse autant vous dire
que ça va être assez facile de créer un
fossé entre les parents détention des
choses comme ça donc ce qui est le plus
important à comprendre en matière de
sexualité c'est que tout joue contre
vous et que si vous comptez sur l'amour
sur la spontanéité et sur la nature va
vous irez amoureusement spontanément et
naturellement droit dans le mur nous
sommes les premières générations à vivre
ce que nous vivons aujourd'hui une vie
sexuelle de 60 ans la possibilité de
choisir d'en tirer du plaisir et donc
c'est tout à fait possible mais par
contre c'est le fruit d'une construction
vous pouvez vivre quelque chose de sympa
au niveau sexuel et c'est possible que
ça dure mais il va falloir apprendre à
communiquer puisque comme je l'aï dit
tout à l'heure c'est un macintosh face à
un pc n'essayez même pas de comprendre
que pense l'autre
si vous cherchez à lire un fichier pour
l'un avec l'autre ça marchera pas il
faut donc et c'est très important
casser l'éducation vous avez reçu la
remplacer par une éthique sexuelle un
ensemble de règles morales et de valeur
mais qui vous sont propres que vous avez
choisi parce que pour vous l avez un
sens et un intérêt pas parce que les
autres le font les autres et mettre la
main devant la bouche quand on tousse
faut aussi apprendre à communiquer oser
dire ce qu'on aime
osez écouter l'autre même si on comprend
pas si pour lui ou pour elle c'est
important il faut l'écouter et si besoin
c'est raide et parce que c'est pas
simple tout ça mais c'est possible il
faut avant tout vous voir non pas comme
des ennemis ne pas attendre que l'autre
fasse les gestes ou le premier pas parce
que s'il attend la même chose ça peut
durer longtemps
il faut oser aller vers l'autre dire ce
qu'on ressent dire ce qu'on souhaite ne
pas forcément cherché à tout comprendre
c'est trop compliqué et surtout réalisé
que en tant que partenaire sexuel vous
devez avant tout être des complices des
amis et des alliés contre tout le reste
qui sont les ennemis la nature la
société l'usure et l'habitude et grâce à
ça on peut arriver et faire quelque
chose de très sympathique et le très
constructif voilà